Hello, and welcome to this video on the original Animation Blueprint.
In this, we're just going to have a look at the Animation Blueprint that we replaced at the beginning.
So, I've loaded up the Animation Blueprint, and first of all, we'll have a quick look at the Animation Graph.
In here, there are a few noteworthy differences.
For example, we're not splitting the animation by the spine, so that we can play and montage on different areas.
We've just got one default slot, which will allow us to play a montage.
That would take up the entire body at any one time, regardless of if you're moving or not.
The other section here, is we have a Control Rig.
Now, as you can see here on the Control Rig, we've got the Should Do IK trace.
Now, the first thing is, it's only going to do this when it isn't falling.
And what this is here for, is this is for making sure the feet automatically touch the ground.
When I was to come into the right hand side, you can see that we actually have a Control Rig class here,
which I could find and open up.
Now, this looks quite complicated, but what it's doing in most cases,
is it's doing a line trace off the bottom of the feet.
And it's seeing if it hits the ground.
And if it does, it's going to adjust the foot IK, so that the feet actually end up being perfectly on the ground.
And you can see this.
If I was to go back and change my default pawn back to the previous, the original one,
and push play, you can see this here.
So at any one time, the feet are exactly on the floor.
If I was to convert back to our original player character, and play that one,
you can already see at the moment that the feet are floating slightly.
That becomes even more pronounced when we go on an uneven level.
So the other thing that's different about this chart is,
you can see here that the locomotion state is being saved out into a cached pose.
However, it's not directly being used as an input for the default slot.
If we double click on the main state,
you can see that we actually have a relatively different state machine here.
If we were to jump into locomotion, you can see this is where the cached pose is being used.
Now the setup here looks quite a bit different to the previous one that we were working on.
And that's because we're using these elements, the To Falling and the To Land, state aliases.
And these are mainly used to clean up a graph.
Because standardly, if you were to build this setup,
we would need to have a lot of links going through all of these different places
to make sure that you could transition at the correct time.
To get to the To Falling node, we would need to either come from the locomotion or the land.
So we would need to have connections to connect up the jump
or the fall loop from both the locomotion and both of the land.
One for each of these settings.
Now, what this means is, for this falling, these two conduits,
the Is Falling velocity Z and the Is Falling,
are both accessible from the locomotion or the land states, because they're ticked on here.
And the same for the To Land.
This conduit, Is Not Falling, would be accessible from the jump or the fall loop.
So these clear up a lot of the messy spaghetti that you would see.
The other thing that's worth noting here is where we standardly went into the jump node,
as soon as you weren't falling.
In this we have two conditions.
We're actually checking to see if the velocity is going up on the Z.
So it's only going to go to the jump if your velocity heading upwards is quite strong.
Otherwise, it's going to jump immediately into the fall.
This means, and I'll demonstrate in a second,
we're going to have smoother transitions if you just run off the edge.
So if we check that out now.
So this was the animation blueprint we put together.
And as you can see, when she falls off, it's a rather odd animation.
A combination of the jump.
And here is the original blueprint.
And as you can see, it's a lot smoother falling off.
It's just going straight into the drop without the jump.
So with that, that will bring us to the end of this video.
So I mainly wanted to make sure that you could understand the difference between the
animation blueprint we created and the one standardly you get with this template.
Thank you for watching.